we finally gotten our first official
look at Nintendo's ninth generation
console the switch details were light in
the days after its official announcement
based on first impressions it sure seems
like the new system could be capable of
going head to head with the Xbox one and
the PlayStation 4 here's a rundown on
what we know about the Nintendo switched
so far and how it will stack up against
the competition
it's a console and a portable by now you
may be wondering why Nintendo called its
new console the switch well check this
out that's crazy
that's right with this new console
gamers will be able to switch from
playing at home or on the go the trailer
shows more scenarios like playing on a
park bench on an airplane and even on
the road and when you've gotten to where
you're going just plug that thing back
into the TV from what we can see in the
trailer the switch seems nowhere near as
bulky as the Wii U gamepad instead
Nintendo's latest console has a sleek
and slim design that's more reminiscent
of a tablet ever since 1989 Nintendo has
dominated the handheld gaming market
Microsoft never really did much with its
tablet base smart glass project and
Sony's portable ambitions with the PSP
and PlayStation Vita could never touch
Nintendo
if the switch can truly deliver on the
promise of being a fully functional home
portable hybrid Nintendo will give
Microsoft and Sony a run for their money
the mighty joique on the switches
detachable controllers called joi cons
will give players tons of options these
two little doohickeys can be attached to
one controller hub the switch console
itself can be used like we style
nunchucks or even as individual
controllers for multiple players that's
four different configurations for one
device and then there's also the
Nintendo switch pro controller that made
an appearance in the trailer while Sony
and Microsoft both offer traditional
style wireless controllers for their
consoles they have nothing like the joy
cons adaptability mobile multiplayer
Nintendo wants to bring back local
multiplayer in a big way the trailer
shows more than one switch console being
linked together
apparently wirelessly it seems like a
fair bet that the switch will have some
form of Wi-Fi built-in too but until
Nintendo tells us more
we're only guessing the switch also
looks like it's built with eSports in
mind with two teams of gamers getting
together to duke it out over a game of
splatoon
kick it with the stand back in the
Gamecube days Nintendo decided to stick
a little handle on their flagship
console so you could carry it around
like a lunchbox which cost $200 this
time around however the switch looks
like it's truly equipped for gameplay
anywhere anytime why it's got a
kickstand this may not seem important
but small details like this can make or
break a device if you're tired of
holding the whole console you can set it
up on a table and get comfortable as far
as design decisions go that little tiny
piece of plastic is actually kind of
brilliant putting the cart before the
disc the rumors are true Nintendo is
ditching discs in favor of cartridges
the switch seems to run on small game
cards apparently similar in size and
shape to 3ds game cards unfortunately
Nintendo confirmed that the switch won't
play Wii U discs or 3ds cartridges still
it's possible the switch might rely on
SD cards just like the 3ds for
expandable internal storage meaning
players might be able to carry lots of
games on each card either way that means
lots of games on the go
Nvidia visuals on the same day that
Nintendo's switch trailer went live
Nvidia announced that it had provided
the console with a custom Tegra
processor quote based on the same
architecture as the world's top
performing GeForce gaming graphics cards
of course a consoles perfomance can't be
summed up by knowing just one of its
components that's under the hood and as
of the making of this video
Nintendo hasn't revealed any of switch's
internal hardware specs
however the trailer gives us a glimpse
at someone playing a game that sure does
look like Skyrim both on the go and on
television an article on ARS technica
speculates that the switch will switch
between 720p and 1080p visuals depending
on whether it's on the go or in the dock
we won't know how close it'll stack up
to the PlayStation 4 the Xbox one until
we know more about the internal specs
but it seems safe to say that it won't
look like well this new exclusives and a
third party party for years Nintendo has
struggled to attract third-party game
makers to make software for its consoles
it's obviously way too early to know
whether or not the switch will remedy
that problem in the long run but
Nintendo revealed that nearly 50
third-party publishers and developers
have committed to their new console we
know the switch will have new games
featuring Super Mario The Legend of
Zelda and Mario Kart but having top-tier
triple-a games from the likes of
Bethesda yet
and Capcom that could help switch get
hardcore gamers on board while also
appealing to lifelong Nintendo fans and
casual gamers alike waiting to flip the
switch for all we know or think we know
there's still plenty we don't as of the
making of this video we're still in the
dark about the switches full tech specs
its launch titles its actual release
date or even the consoles purchase price
how long will the batteries last how
much will it cost to replace a joke on
after one of them gets thrown out the
window during a vigorous session of
minivan Mario Kart because that's
totally going to happen but even with
the little information we do have it
seems like Nintendo wants the switch to
make waves could this be the console
Nintendo meant to make when the Wii U
flopped will it capture the attention
and hard-earned cash of casual and
hardcore game fans alike shut up and
take my money only time will tell but
one thing's for sure we've never seen a
console like this before in the end
there's only one thing we can say to
Nintendo about the switch
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know what you think
about the Nintendo switch